meantime the panic defined baby formula
continues all across the valley and
tonight we hear from one mom who is
struggling to find formula for not just
one baby but three victoria saha has
more on her story and what a struggle
she's going through yeah denise it's an
ordeal parents of infants and babies
never expected to go through and mom of
triplets says she's just taking it day
by day hoping there is an end to this or
her babies don't go hungry
nine-month-old triplets camila khaleesi
and cataleya have big appetites
they go through 15 bottles a day which
means a can of formula runs out fast
it's very stressful
trying to make sure that they're fed and
that they have what they need
when it's nowhere to be found finding
the right baby formula has become a
daunting task for mom lydia flores she
goes out on a mission every two days
there was a few times that i was like
freaking out and i had to drive around
town
like all day trying to find at least one
can of formula and before one can ends
the worry kicks in about the next one
when this one's gone and i can't find
another one we went to local stores to
see for ourselves the dire situation
happening right now i just stopped by a
target here and came to the baby formula
aisle you can see the shelves are pretty
much empty i was able to talk to a store
associate who tells me they get a
shipment in every day but they pretty
much sell out almost immediately here at
walmart they have a lot more in stock
but the majority of their shelves are
empty a couple people have suggested
goat milk if it gets too bad i've even
thought about a friend suggested trying
to re-lactate
like to try to pump milk
for now they are hoping to make it until
the girls can start solid food
there could be a light at the end of the
tunnel i spoke with the nevada retail
association they say they are hoping
with president biden making his drastic
decision today to give formula makers a
priority to get ingredients that our
shelves would be stocked within six
weeks